rick astley coming in studio I already
know what I'm gonna ask him that's d-bag
not Rick Astley I don't know most say
that when he comes in we're gonna show
you are never gonna give you up big song
for you alright
why would you say that just to get the
ball rolling up I have a lot to say
about it yeah change my life let's find
out is the eyes ears he Rick Astley how
about - good Rick Astley am I right or
wrong Travis and say we wrong you're
right yeah okay welcome come on in we're
live we're on so make yourself
comfortable
welcome to the show welcome to the
program how are ya how's it goin
good to see you man good how are you
good good good good you got new music
coming out everybody's talking about you
this is a this is a good time to be Rick
Astley right I'm not complaining yeah
it's been it's been obviously havin
doing a new record for years and years
and years so it's kind of been a bit odd
but we had a good start in the UK we
released it in June and we had a number
one album how can we do one in a long
time well I retired really early I
retired runs about 28 I'll become a dad
I'd had a few hits and what I've um had
travelled the world a few times and been
doing it for four or five years and I
just got sick of it if I'm honest I'll
just kind of just had enough of it and
all those groupies right they get old
same woman for like 27 28 years so when
even so when did you marry I actually
mentioned 87 but we actually got
together in 89 and my first record was
87 so she used to work at a record label
in Denmark so that's how we met but you
had 87 to 89 not being in that committed
relationship I was in a different one
relationship that's better though man
when you got going hit in the world it's
always better let me have a girlfriend
you have to call who wants to have sex
with a bunch of what I feel sorry for
the guys on girls out there today
because you can't do anything today if
you even if somebody winks at you in a
bar it's all over you know
Facebook YouTube god knows what you know
means right yeah I mean I don't I just
don't have people do anything anymore do
you mean yeah we you're called out
somebody posted one of my penis photos
on Twitter did because you know it's
just what that's just what a sister does
it was just because it was someone who
freaked out some wacko ID sent a dick
picture to in a bun to I'm adding care
it's like dude no singles just rewind
from your second listen this is New York
it's kind of it's a moment for me did
you just say you sent a dick picture to
someone oh god yes you never done that
Rick the more Matt the more amazing
thing the more amazing thing is people I
haven't sent them to okay who deserved
them do me a favor don't send me any
I'll email it so if you don't open the
attachment it's understandable don't you
think it'd be charming if like even
can't be your wife you know you send her
a dick pic and just under it you're
right never gonna give you up married
couples don't do that like that that's
not a married couple thing that's more
like when you're getting into it but I
don't know many married couples that
send each other naked this kind of over
it yeah I mean listen I also think that
this we're all different aren't we and I
don't I don't see I don't see that as a
special moment between two people
sending them a dick pic but hey whatever
that's me maybe I'm just old-fashioned -
you're probably right what did you meet
osseous on the prep sheet Jim Norton
interview extraordinaire I yes yeah yeah
no I mean yeah that was a weird moment
to be honest I was staying at Hotel in
Los Angeles which I always stayed in
it's kind of a bit of a rock and roll
hotel a lot of music and film people
stay there and we were just waiting and
used to have a tiny little bar it's now
kind of got a great bar that everybody
goes to and it's a bit of a scene but he
used to have this tiny little bar and if
you're waiting for your ride or
what-have-you just go in there and get a
drink before you go in and sure enough
Ozzy Osbourne's in there and his wife
Sharon's in there and they just sat
there and I was just minding my own
business and he kind of recognized me
and kind of said what you do need are
you doing gigs and kind of thing I said
no no I'm interested to do some promo
and what-have-you he said have you got a
band I said well we're just putting one
together at the moment you know cuz
we're touring soon and he said well I've
played with all the best musicians in
the world you know
I can put your ID and find you some
great players which he has to be fair
he's played with all the greats you
rightly know people have left his band
have gone on to you know careers in
their own right but Sharon then kind of
just chips in so with that little sharin
chips in and literally literally just
stops Ozzy Osbourne in his tracks and
says he doesn't want to play with your
longer tape monsters Jeremy it's kind of
like he's a nice like leave him alone
and that was just it was just the
dynamic of it was pretty amazing but
obviously we all know Sharon now and we
know you know we know what character and
what she's like and she's a forceful
woman you know but it was a pretty odd
situation to be in in in a bar in a
rock-and-roll hotel with you know the
Emperor of Darkness or whatever you want
to call him and and in being kind of
Chester I believe it's just the printer
do you feel like though like when
because there are still like you see
sexting scandals and people are like
you're talking about like the kids now
or performing I'm sure not in in 87 88
89 yeah if you weren't in a relationship
and we had the technology we do today
you probably would have had all that
[ __ ] all all of your [ __ ] out there yeah
yeah for sure I mean listen we had we
had paparazzi storm we had all of that
you know you said the gangs are
photographers and everything but the big
thing now is if someone takes your
picture I mean it's there it's done it's
worldwide it that's it any forever
yeah whereas in those days that kind of
like some guy have to go and run off get
that process yeah you know so this that
and the other bit that was a totally
different world in it in terms of
privacy but I mean obviously privacy was
still invaded especially for you know
big Hollywood stars especially and stuff
like that and maybe some big music
artists really big ones but I think it
was it just wasn't so instant you know
mean mm-hmm
so maybe people had time to prepare for
things as well do you know I mean kind
of that storms coming we better get
ready you know I mean whereas now it's
just boom you know I mean it's kind of
it's crazy what are you doing you retire
that young yeah just hang out yeah well
I've become a dad and my mom and dad
divorced when I was very very young I'm
the youngest of four kids also they had
a son who passed away before I was born
very young and so for me having a very
kind of solid family setup was really
important like this to all of us of
course it is but for me I looked at
myself sometimes in the mirror in some
far doing that we all hate no but I'd
sometimes would you know be in a hotel
somewhere and just thinking what are you
doing here you've got a one-year-old
daughter at home and also if I'm honest
I've made quite you know a bit of money
and it's kind of it's very easy at that
point in your life to look at pop music
especially and say how long is this
going to last
do I want it to last what what is
actually going on here and I think I
just kind of I just fell out of love
with the whole business side of it you
know I mean I never fell out of love
with music I've always had a lot of
studios I've always close with my
friends in little bands and done little
mess about projects and stuff but I just
didn't want to do that whole thing
anymore I wanted to be at home you know
Wow but the money kept rolling in from
that song from that obviously I thought
you know they send me checks every day
yeah yeah yeah
well what's that like when cuz we're
talking about it before you came in that
you sold something like what is it 15
million yeah record something like that
night you used it you used to sell
records in those days right means right
right but but to go from there to being
like okay now now this is the the pace
that I've set for myself yeah now I got
to keep matching this I would assume
that that has a lot to do with why you
want to kind of get out of it because
now you have this unrealistic thing
where it's like no I have to get up to
what was never gonna get my first single
never gonna give you up you know was my
biggest record as well and that's a
weird feeling to have because it was
1987 and I was the only one and and
sorry I haven't heard that you have note
that one okay I'll send you a I'll send
you an email with a little link in it
well to a two-degree because it's kind
of all downhill from there no it's like
it's that helpful no no but what it felt
like was that you can the chasing your
tail a little bit I would go to
countries that I barely knew about and
I'd been number one for a couple of
weeks which is an amazing feeling of
course it is but you also feel I felt a
little bit like an impostor sometimes I
felt a bit like this is happening to
some other guy and you think it's
happening to me when I'd get there do
you know I mean because it's like I got
to Sweden I've been number one for weeks
I'm like I've never been here you know I
don't know anything about Sweden what
are we what's happening what's going on
and and I think and the other thing is
as well maybe people get a bit of
training these days I didn't know
anything I didn't know what was gonna
happen I've never had never even walked
into a radio station before but what
about yours consciously cute I do is
like like a would you just start you got
one yeah you got a couple of really big
songs off that record book what are you
open with and what do you do yes people
get impatient waiting for that song I
mean that's the thing I usually play it
last to be honest and every now and
again if the audience is getting a bit
rowdy or something's going on I'll just
do it acoustically and actually say to
people you know okay you can go and get
your boss now because we've done that
once you don't I mean you don't do it no
I do it for real but I'm saying in the
middle of the set I'll do it a cappella
or something just so that they can
listen to it and go home do you not I
mean they can video I put it on YouTube
brick wall somebody and then go on you
know I mean yeah we did it yeah yeah but
I mean it's a funny thing with that song
of course it is because it's had its
life on the internet in a totally
different way these last few years must
have made millions off that I've
obviously made some money from it for
sure but I mean it's not it I didn't
write it so it's not anything to do with
me publishing wise it's tough but
suppose I'm not knocking it of course
it's opened doors and it's done some
things and it's kind of given that song
a new lease of life and I'm sure a lot
of people can't stand it and never ever
want to hear it ever again were you
annoyed when it started though lately
because because I really understand the
dealers if I'm honest and also I've said
you didn't get it not really a friend of
mine who lives in LA from then off
because it started in America and he
emailed me and rickrolled me and on
holiday and I just kind of emailed him
back coin you ask you know what you're
doing and and and he did it again okay
and he's English by the way sorry
so I you know picked up the phone just
said what are you doing you know like
what what are you and then he explained
it to me and and I still didn't really
get it if I'm honest because you're
going back a few years when that
happened and if you think about YouTube
and stuff and the way that things were
on the Internet that was in its infancy
to a great degree
you didn't go to YouTube for every
single thing that's ever have ever been
filmed whereas today you do if you want
to find some early you know footage of
the Beatles playing in some what have
you it'll be on there right if you want
to go and see you know some presidential
this that any other from night in
whatever it'll be on everything's on
there you know I mean everything is on
there who ever thought like I always
wonder who does this the first time
whoever rickrolled whoever came up with
that is a genius
like what there's a mine out there that
said I want to fool somebody oh yeah
that song that's perfect together and
just created that that it is weird and I
love I have thought about that
occasionally of course I have my
daughter at the time was about 15 and
she kind of popped me right really and
just kind of said look it's got nothing
to do with you just let it be don't
don't get involved just don't just leave
it alone it's nothing to do with you
that's not that's not great advice so
because you could have put out an app
you could have done something cuz I read
I read on the Internet yeah that for the
first three years at least of
rickrolling you made like 12 bucks so I
don't know the copies are on me I've
never sat down to work or asked anybody
and to be honest I don't really care I
mean being flippant about money it's
just I think the more that you look at
it I've done a couple of things where I
came in Rick Rolled Macy's Day Parade I
saw in 2008 Macy's day sorry JC's parade
on Thanksgiving you know and I did that
because I thought it well I did that
because I called every American friend
and every friend I've got here lives in
America and they all screamed back down
the phone and said you have to do that
you have to do that yeah and and I've
been in New York on that day before and
I've kind of felt that you know what
goes on and everything but to actually
just be in the parade even in a daft way
like that when did you do it at what
point what was happening it was actually
come outside Macy's that's when all of
the cameras
they're obviously on your you know and
it was a it was a kids hoppy animation
show right and they they wanted me to
that so their songs playing in the
puppets there you go and and I came out
and Rick Rolled them let's take it the
middle of the song he just walks out
behind the float thing the wid thing and
the pretty amazing thing was to go
through New York on a float when there's
no traffic there's no nothing the AMA
traffic is the floating frontier you
know spongebob squarepants is the only
truck I mean it yeah it was it was
amazing to see New York that way to be
honest it's pretty crazy yeah what was
it like with the award in 2008 that you
offered to not you Norton I only said I
have got that award because I asked them
for it what it was it was MTV thought
they were being really best act ever
yeah well I best live act older which I
mean you sure you would put me in that
category for 15 years as well and not
done a gig for that long the north's
through it they thought they would be an
ironic and funny because of the
rickrolling thing yeah and then the
great European public thought it'd be
ironic and funny to vote for me so I
want right actually got more votes than
people live in Europe action exactly
what went on there but but I just said
look I'm not coming because it's
ridiculous you've got you've got Bono
Sir Paul McCartney an award a Lifetime
Achievement Award in Liverpool right and
then you expect me to get on the stage
and accept an award for being the best
live act ever yeah yeah no to shake volt
there would you admit embarrass meeting
that why yes okay but we got the award
though because my daughter really liked
it because it's a wobbly spaceman so we
thought we'd go for that yeah that's
interesting you because McCartney was
gonna be there and Bono and you're like
you want you don't want to like be
[ __ ] with like with the listen it
would have been nice to going to be
there just to see that and to see you
know I mean and some of the other stuff
but not to receive an award for that
because because it was a joke basically
and nothing in the end the joke was a
little bit on them because I want it you
know yeah right you know you two are in
that category and everything you can't
even put us on the same planet
but yeah I've never been all rolled
anyone sir over there you go let's stop
let's do it
that's true why have you have you
decided what like
that you realize there's an interest now
now you come back I know a lot of people
obviously a so you know would think I'm
doing this because there's been Rick
Rolled in brick wall has been going for
years and I haven't really yeah yeah
yeah so and to be honest yeah it's had a
bubble on the internet and people do
other things at the moment there's a
campaign in the UK for me to be the
England football manager which is pretty
good I would take that job before you
might so there's been loads of different
stuff in around that tune and
what-have-you but to be honest it was
more because having been doing gigs
again for about ten years all over the
world really one of the things that you
get because of social media people tell
you obviously what they think of the gig
and you know why didn't you play this
song or we really love that song there
but one of the main things was when
you're gonna make a new record
you know we'd like a new record and to
be honest I've never I haven't had the
confidence to make a new record because
you feel a bit irrelevant at some point
in your life is now you're telling the
right people irrelevance is not fair
that's not that's not really a fair way
to put it but I think you just sort of
think who's really other than your
immediate fans you know is anybody
really bothered right and then at some
point you and like you know I knew 50
was coming and I just said some so at
some point I don't care I'm gonna make a
record because I want to so basically
I've got a studio at home it's right
behind the kitchen and I made the record
myself I wrote everything played every
instrument just made the record right so
didn't even have a record label to be
honest I just thought I just want to
make some music do that and I think you
know it's just have been a really
natural process a really enjoyable one
and then I went to my old record label
BMG and they really wanted to do it so
we did it and yeah it just went boom in
the UK it was crazy that's our number
one yeah good for you Rick Astley has to
go that you can follow him on Rick
Astley ast ly on Twitter yes and Rick
Astley CEO UK and I believe this would
be a taste off his new album
very good yeah yeah not exactly say they
sound the same but they're not quite
this is called I'm so happy I gave you
up